8 news now reporter Mary Jane beliesza
shares how immigration groups in the
valley are preparing ahead of one title
42 expires
title 42
expected to be lifted May 11th
immigration attorneys like diesel are
anticipating a rise in Asylum cases the
problem will be as title 42 comes down
it's always a struggle just like the
average American
um to get access to council under title
42 migrants seeking Asylum at the border
were turned away as part of a public
health policy to mitigate the spread of
covet 19. the displacement of people has
been growing and probably will grow
for years to come until we get a handle
on some Global Solutions Alyssa Cooley
managing attorney at the UNLV
immigration Clinic says while anyone
entering the U.S can seek Asylum the
process can be lengthy there's a common
misconception I'm sure you've heard it
like just do it the right way
well actually to apply for to ask for
Asylum at the border is the right way
Cooley says they won't know the local
impact until title 42 actually expires
but expect an increased demand for help
there will be an increased demand for
for help and think a lot of these
families have been waiting in Mexico for
three years probably living in a shelter
may be able to find work enough to feed
themselves cooling knows there will be
an immigration backlog that could take
years to file the number of Asylum
Seekers at that point was already very
high because it had been 18 months two
years at that point but now we made it
unnecessarily longer you know so like we
created it
unlv's immigration Clinic is just one of
many immigration organizations across
the valley we do have a list of
additional resources on our website at
8newsnow.com